President Trump is celebrating Christmas
at his Mar lager resort in Florida this
morning last night the President and
First Lady attended a Christmas Eve
service at the Palm Beach church where
they were married in 2005 the members of
the congregation gave the couple a
standing ovation earlier they surprised
children who called in to the North
American Aerospace Defense Command to
track Santa Clauses travels chip Reid is
with the president in West Palm Beach
Florida
chip good morning well good morning
president Trump and First Lady Melania
Trump called 22 children across the
country the president also claimed to
have brought back the phrase Merry
Christmas
tweeting I am proud to have led the
charge against the assault of our
cherished and beautiful phrase over the
weekend the president continued his
assault on FBI deputy director Andrew
McCabe who he accuses of bias in the
investigation of Hillary Clinton's
emails CBS News has learned that McCabe
is expected to retire by this March
Democrats say the president is simply
trying to divert attention from the
Special Counsel investigation of his
campaigns contacts with Russia the
president also continued to south
support for the new tax law tweeting our
insider polls are strong but he did not
say what specific polls he's talking
about in CBS News polls show that only
35 percent of Americans support the new
tax overhaul
Tony chip read for us in florida chip
thank you very much